alain vidalis le ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous pour ce rendez-vous de public
sénat avec l' agence france-presse
et dailymotion est avec nous tout à
l'heure karine perret de la fp et puis
perrine tarneaud de public sénat
monsieur le ministre les chiffres du
chômage viennent de tomber en il
s'apparente à un supplice chinois
supplémentaire j'ai envie de dire pour
l'exécutif dans cet entre deux tours des
élections municipales avec une forte
hausse au mois de février plus 31500
demandeurs d'emploi une première
réaction c'est une augmentation a marqué
31500 en catégorie a qui peut être
légèrement atténué si on regarde sur
l'ensemble des catégories à b et c c'est
à dire les demandeurs d'emploi qui n'ont
pas exercé une activité à plein temps
sur moi ou sur trois mois on est à 7500
pour pour cela je pense que il faut
regarder ces chiffres avec trois
indicateurs qui sont publiés aujourd'hui
le premier indicateur celui d' activités
économiques là les chiffres du chômage
chez ceux du mois de mars l'indicateur
de l'activité économique c'est le
chômage pardon c'est du mois de février
un indicateur économique c'est celui du
mois de mars par oui ça repart un peu
même bien puisque c'est la première fois
depuis trente et remarquent pas être
technique mais l'indicateur à partir
quand on est au dessus de 50 ça veut
dire que la croissance repart on se
situer ces dernières années où depuis
ces derniers mois depuis 31 mois autour
de 47 46 51 3 ces deux autres chemises
et la deuxième raison elle est
aujourd'hui dans la presse ce matin je
prends la presse économique du travail
l'écart se réduit avec l'allemagne c'est
pas le résultat du hasard il suffit de
regarder à l'intérieur de cet article ce
qui est expliqué que c'est la
conséquence du
de la mise en place du cicr par le
gouvernement pourquoi je dis ça parce
qu'il faut regarder et répondre à la
question qu'est ce que vous faites par
rapport au problème du chômage si vous
regarder dans le détail des chiffres qui
vont être qui vient d'être dans le
détail mais il faut quand même qu'on
retienne le chiffre essentiel c'est plus
de 30 mille francs qui sont à 31 ans
basculer dans la catégorie ya ce sont
des drames d'office savoir qui c'est et
ça mérite un peu plus de précisions je
voulais dénoncer pas celle là
avant les donnes jozami j'invite chacun
à la réflexion là dessus le chômage des
jeunes augmente très peu 1500 de plus
mais sur neuf mois il recule il y à
aujourd'hui en france un problème très
particulier qui l'a explose dans les
statistiques y compris ce mois ci c'est
les plus de 50 ans c'est à dire qu'on
est dans la situation aujourd'hui ou sur
un an est une bonne période de réflexion
on a un chômage qui augmente pour qui
pour les jeunes de moins de 20 ans
diminue de 1 25% mais qui pour les plus
de 50 ans et à +12 virgules alors pour
ça c'est vrai depuis plusieurs mois vous
vous envisager des mesures spécifiques
pour les seniors je pense que la
question est posée aujourd'hui à la fois
de la réalité de cette statistique là et
qui entraîne en plus une divergence avec
les chiffres du bureau international du
travail alors qu'il faut qu'on regarde
ça de près mais je pense que cette
réalité là elle mérite d'être précisée
parce que les gens nous demandent
d'apporter des réponses et on voit bien
aujourd'hui qu'on est confronté à une
exclusion du marché du travail les plus
de 50 ans une progression marquée un de
ceux de nombre de chômage en france
vous le reconnaissez évidemment je le
disais ce sont à chaque fois des
souffrances individuelles pour les
familles mais ça va encore peser plus
lourd dimanche prochain dans les urnes
il nous faut la transparence dans la
situation économique cde pas caché les
chiffres cessé de les donner
même si c'est la réalité d'aujourd'hui
est ce que nous demande le sens me till
les concitoyens c'est qu'est ce que vous
faites quel est votre réponse
il y en a d'autres que possible n'y a
pas qu'une seule politique mène un autre
électeur on l'a engagé c'est pour ça que
j'ai parlé de l'activité économique et
j'ai parlé de l'article des échos ce
matin sur le différentiel du coût du
travail avec l'allemagne c'est soit le
résultat du hasard c'est le résultat de
la politique qu'on a mis en oeuvre et je
préfère si vous voulez avoir un
indicateur économique à mettre en avant
les éléments positifs pour le comprend
enfin le lin verserait à ces cessions
vont bien sûr vous pouvez le faire vous
même sur les éléments négatifs c'est
aussi votre travail mais je pense qu'il
ya un ensemble de choses que je voulais
finir ma france et il vaut mieux avoir
un indicateur d'activité économique pour
le mois de mars à dire pour aujourd'hui
qu'ils soient bons porteurs d'espoir que
l'inversé leurs politiques négatives
dites moi le climat ce mercredi matin en
conseil des ministres il ne veut pas
être positif très honnêtement il était
assez assez ordinaire j'ai pas si
quelques membres ans que l'état est
intervenu mauvais score des socialistes
le premier tour des mi moyens
quel était son message le message du
chef de l'état il a été très clair il a
dit dès lors qu'il ya une élection il
faut tirer les conséquences
entendre ce qu'on dit les français qui
ont voté at il ajouté y compris entendre
ceux qui ne sont pas de nouveauté il
faut prendre son expression dans sa
globalité et donc il est dit il faut
préparer le second tour puisque c'est le
rassemblement qui doit qui doit
l'emporter explique et encore plus si
c'est nécessaire
ce qu'on a fait mais naturellement il
faudra en tirer les conséquences et
veiller les abstentionnistes de gauche
qui effectivement ont fait défaut oui ce
que toujours un peu le cas par rapport
au parti qui est au pouvoir si on fait
la comparaison avec avec 2008 mais il ya
aussi un message qui est assez simple
c'est que peut penser dans tous les cas
c'est ce qu'on nous dit qu'un certain
nombre de personnes ne sont pas venus
voter parce que les résultats ne sont
pas au rendez vous que la politique
sociale leur leur déplaît donc ce
raisonnement là il est valable au
premier tour puisqu'il n'a il n'a pas
beaucoup de conséquences au second tour
l'idée de s'abstenir
à pour faire élire la droite qui pour le
coup personne va prétendre que sur le
plan social c'est là qu'on va trouver
des solutions j'attire l'attention de
chacun je prends un seul exemple on a eu
des débats à l'assemblée nationale ont
peu le pas être d'accord avec la réforme
des retraites qui a été fait par ce
gouvernement mais enfin quand on ajoute
la pénibilité que nous on maintient à
l'accès à 62 ans de l'âge de la retraite
et en face on a quoi on a une droite qui
dit non c'est c'est 65 ans là on a signé
hier le décret qui pour les personnes
qui travaillent à temps partiel permet
de valider un trimestre à partir de 150
heures vous êtes tout ça ce sont des
choses qui doivent être président à vos
électeurs ça va on a bien compris on a
reçu la gifle c'est pas la peine de nous
en remettre une deuxième dimanche 5 ou
leur dit c'est une image non pour
résumer comme ça on peut la résumer
comme ça selon bruno le roux le patron
des députés ps françois hollande estime
que cette gifle du premier tour est une
forme d'injustice
c'est une forme d'injustice pour vous
savez les électeurs sont jamais sont
jamais injuste à les électeurs bien sûr
que nous ça ne paraît pas affecter juste
pour les autos ténue du maire sortant et
qui ont subi le contrôle politique c'est
normal ils ont toujours ce sentiment là
mais enfin quand on a un engagement
politique il vaut pour yvo pour cette
globalité
donc je peux y avoir ici ou là un
sentiment un sentiment d'injustice mais
suffrage universel n'est jamais n'ai
jamais refusé un gouvernement qui n'est
pas professionnel pas suffisamment
professionnel c'est harlem désir qu'il
dit que presse que vous réagissez
écoutez pas qu'il a comme qualité de
grand témoin pour projet de ça on peut
toujours s'améliorer il faut avoir
beaucoup d'humilité dans la façon dont
on dirige les affaires de l'état et de
ce point de vue là même pas l'intention
de donner des leçons à qui que ce soit
ce que je veux dire quand même parce que
je suis témoin je suis en relation avec
tous les ministres est souvent compte
tenu de ma fonction
franchement tout ce travail beaucoup
sont très engagés sur leurs ministères
le font avec conviction donc là il ya
une sorte d'injustice vous le dites il
ya une appréciation mais je prends ça
comme un encouragement vrai que le héros
bashing amplifiée par des vous des
ténors même du parti socialiste il vous
choque
quel ténor ben on peut
on peut quand même heure alors je vous
avertis d'un ténor c'est votre
appréciation ce n'est pas la mienne mais
on a entendu jean bienvenue aussi par
exemple
ça a été tellement c'était on a entendu
bertrand delanoë parler d'une claque
pour le gouvernement s'était c'était
différent ils mettaient pas en cause
déverser directement je les préfère
l'appréciation qui est fait en général
et qui est juste de là ce qui est
insupportable c'est les attaques
personnelles
le dire attaqué attaqué un homme
on a mené cette politique le président
la république a été du sony politiques
ont amené cette politique avec un
premier ministre qui jamais n'a failli à
sa tâche à la solidarité qui toujours a
été pour essayer de dégager des
consensus a vait légaux parlementaire
qui a été très présent dans le dialogue
moi je trouve que il peut y avoir des
décisions qu'ils relèvent pas évidemment
de l'appréciation des ministres mais
uniquement du président de la république
mais ça peut se justifier pour des
raisons politiques pas pour des raisons
personnelles alors on se dit que
l'impulsion le même le choc un
nécessaire passe par un changement de
tête à matignon
ça c'est votre appréciation est-ce
qu'elle sera partagée par le président
de la république je ne sais pas savez ce
n'est pas une règle absolue pour
reprendre votre expression la droite a
pris une gifle à peu près comparable en
il me semble que monsieur fillon est
lassé premier ministre m'ont voyez il
n'y a pas de règle absolue il avait même
vous avez même prime déjà une gifle en
2004 et monsieur raffarin était était
premier ministre alors ceux qui
aujourd'hui vont sur les plateaux en dix
ans il faudrait presque qu'ils
démissionnent avant le 2e dan avant le
deuxième taux peut-être un peu de
sagesse
est ce que le sérieux le maintien de
jean marc ayrault à matignon est une
hypothèse crédible
oui c'est une hypothèse crédible le
président de la république n'a pas dit
qu'il allait changer de premier ministre
il n'a pas non plus dit qu'il est
confirmé c'est sa décision
mais voilà l'eurobashing n'a n'a aucun
fondement il peut y avoir d'autres
raisons qui justifient la décision du
président est dans tous les cas c'est
lui appartient et à lui seul et tous les
autres commentaires me semble inutile
superflue
à vrai dire parfois assez désagréable
par rapport au premier ministre quand
tous les cas il ya un trio dont on parle
c'est manuel valls laurent fabius
bartolone qui dans deux des candidats
déclarés à matignon que pensez vous de
ces hypothèses on n'est pas candidat à
matignon
donc tous ceux qui pensent être candidat
à matignon ils sont candidats à rien
cette audition la république qui choisit
le premier ministre donc les
candidatures ne servent à rien et c'est
le président qui décidera est-ce que
l'entrée au gouvernement de martine
aubry ce si c'est possible
elle serait un bon signal envoyé aux
électeurs de gauche selon vous alain
vidalies si la réponse est est ce que il
faudrait que évidemment que les
personnalités comme ça tout le monde
souhaite qu'elles soient à nos côtés
mais martina aubry a répondu que c'était
pas dans ses projets aujourd'hui qu'elle
est dans la bataille pour la bataille
pour lui on a à la fois la question est
à la fois la réponse est ségolène royal
elle est candidate elle est maintenant
je ne vais pas oui c'est pas de ma
compétence et je vais pas faire ce
casting que je observer et que ça risque
de vous occuper encore pas d'un certain
nombre de jours mais pas plus beaucoup
maintenant apparemment ça peut aller
très vite
pensez vous dès le lendemain ou le
surlendemain du second tour des
municipales
ça je n'en sais rien je vois que vous
faites des pronostics d'abord ça fait
longtemps mais il semble que vous
approchez de la vallée voilà voilà
bon ça c'est un point jean pierre
raffarin était à votre place hier pour
ce preuve par trois il a estimé que le
responsable de la montée du front
national c'était le parti socialiste en
raisons de ses échecs que lui répondez
vous je pense qu'il est plus inspiré
d'habitude et que là c'est probablement
l'énervement d'avant le second tour qui
le conduit à de telles excentricités sur
le plan intellectuel
la montée du front national elle a aussi
eu lieu sauf a vraiment une mauvaise foi
totale sous les gouvernements de droite
et elle obéit à d'autres raisons et puis
sur le plan idéologique c'est pas nous
qui avons créé un ministère de
l'identité nationale c'est pas nous qui
avons essayé avec monsieur buisson de
mener monsieur sarkozy de mener une
campagne pour les élections
présidentielles où se demander
ou tel front national où étaient l'ump
avec des propos qui dépasse et je dirais
le cadre normal de l'expression d'un
parti républicain de droite ça vous
inquiète
le fait qu'il y aura plusieurs villes
front national des marcheurs sur moi je
considère que c'est pas un parti
républicain je le dis très clairement
donc je l' ai déjà dit je pense que
c'est un parti démocrate puisqu'il peut
participer aux élections mais je pense
que ces propos la république c'est
l'égalité la liberté la fraternité la
fraternité c'est pas l'exclusion d'une
partie de la population c'est pas la
stigmatisation d'une partie de la
population et je pense que ça reste un
parti à part parce que il ne répond pas
aux exigences aujourd'hui de ce que doit
être la république mais vous partager
l'opinion de cécile duflot qui lors du
conseil des ministres ce mercredi matin
a expliqué que l'ampleur du vote front
national en fait traduisait une
exaspération sociale
je sais pas si ça peut se résumer à cela
je crois que c'est quand même un peu
plus un peu plus compliqué je pense que
c'est une question de peur de dire ce
sur quoi je vous l'extrême droite qui
n'est pas une création des uniquement la
de 2014
il ya eu des périodes de notre histoire
dans lequel des partis de ce type la
populiste honteux pris de l'ampleur et
toujours en surfant sur l'inquiétude des
gens la peur la peur de l'autre ici
c'est quoi c'est la peur de la
mondialisation c'est la peur la perte
d'identité c'est la peur la peur de
l'autre la peur de notre culture la peur
de tout on fait pas une société en ayant
peur de tout et à l'ayant peur des
autres c'est pour ça que de ces parties
là ils mènent complètement dans
l'impasse dans la division en france on
peut pas se rassembler sur des valeurs
qui repose sur l'exclusion alors le
message est que le message du premier
tour a été entendue c'est ce qu'on a
compris de vos propos je serai présent
alain vidalis et on annonce plus de
justice sociale alors sous quelle forme
peut être que vous allez pouvoir nous le
dire maintenant
vous allez pouvoir répondre aux
questions de karine perret de l' agence
france-presse
mais il faut quand même rappeler que
françois hollande a un agenda bien
défini pour les semaines et les mois qui
viennent entre le pacte de
responsabilité et puis également le
programme d'économies budgétaires 50
milliards d'euros sous l'oeil de
bruxelles
les explications tout de suite pas te de
responsabilité plan d'économies de 50
milliards maîtrise des dépenses
publiques
c'était l'après municipal promis par
françois hollande
mais comment demander ses efforts aux
français sans en rajouter dans la colère
des électeurs de gauche
pour certains députés il faut que le
président corrige à nouveau son cap
celui fixé lors de sa conférence de
presse le 14 janvier dernier où la
politique que nous menons n'est pas la
meilleure elle n'est pas équilibrée elle
ne reprend pas suffisamment en compte
les attentes par exemple des ouvriers
des employés
mais voilà le gouvernement subit aussi
la pression de bruxelles et l'agenda est
déjà bien tracé la france placés sous
surveillance renforcée par la commission
européenne n'a plus qu'une année pour
ramener son déficit public à 3 % et elle
doit présenter à bruxelles les détails
de son pacte de stabilité le mois
prochain alors à bercy on annonce les
comptes désastreux pour la france pour
le gouvernement actuel
le débat est donc clos et pour le
ministre michel sapin économiser 50
milliards d'euros de dépenses publiques
c'est l'intérêt supérieur de la france
voilà donc pour ce rappel signé jérôme
monod avec plus de justice sociale
concrètement quel geste fiscal
pourriez-vous faire je pense que vous
avez fait presque toute la totalité de
la question et de la réponse le champ
peut être effectivement le champ fiscal
mais aucune décision n'a été prise à
venir
c'est un peu la suite d'une réforme qui
a été lancé d'ailleurs par le premier
ministre une réforme de la fiscalité des
ménages et à du travail qui se fait
aujourd'hui dont on ne peut pas donner
les conclusions
ça veut dire que c'est cette réforme là
reste d'actualité mais on pourrait
annoncer des mesures ou quelques grandes
lignes avant le deuxième tour pour dire
qu'on a compris le message des ions
dimanche dernier oui mais l'idée c'est
d'avoir une déclaration de politique qui
parlera à la fois du pack de
responsabilité des économies de la
trajectoire des finances celle inverse
de la démagogie je veux pas bien ici
dire les choses c'est le plan c'est la
totalité c'est équilibré ce sera annoncé
par le président de la république et il
y aura une question va la responsabilité
du gouvernement sera engagée par le
premier temps l'assemblée nous préciser
la nature de l'intervention que fera le
chef de l'état à l'issue du second tour
monsieur je ne sais pas si son
intervention portera de sur le détail de
ce long temps pas mais dans tous les cas
c'est une question de jours puisque vous
l'avez vous même rappelé il ya une
échéance à fin avril à la trajectoire
des finances publiques vis-à-vis de
bruxelles dont chacun sait qu'il y aura
probablement d'ici fin avril dans tous
les cas l'engagement de responsabilité
du gouvernement devant l'assemblée
nationale et que se brûle cet engagement
de responsabilité il se fera sur le
pacte de responsabilité mais aussi sur
l'ancien oui mais voilà la question que
karine c'était avant parce que ce matin
on a entendu au conseil des ministres
j'avais à l'aube el kacem nous dire on
va pas entendu ça veut dire que quand on
s'engage à tirer les conséquences de ce
que disent les électeurs même et une
élection ces deux tours franchement
faire des annonces entre les entre les
deux tours ce serait démagogique vous
dites oui fois très honnêtement
je trouve que ce serait assez malvenu et
dans tous les cas c'est pas la
conception de la politique du président
du produit on a envie de savoir ce
qu'est ce que vous allez pouvoir
annoncer pour les que je viens de vous
dire je vais pas vous annoncer
aujourd'hui ce que ce que le président
de la république et le premier ministre
et diront dans quelques jours
naturellement est-ce que c'était une
erreur par exemple de supprimer les
mesures sur la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires
c'était un choix on peut en débattre
mais c'était un choix elles sont
aujourd'hui est ce que dans un pays et
qui a trois millions de demandeurs
d'emploi c'était intéressant de dépenser
4 milliards 4 milliards par an pour
permettre à ceux qui avaient déjà un
travail de continuer à faire d'autres
enfin la mesure jusqu'à ce que vous
annoncez pour les foyers modestes elle
coûtera beaucoup plus cher peut-être
peut-être 10 milliards d'euros
je vous parle de politique de l'emploi
nous avons fait un transfert de ces
sommes là puisque c'est à peu près le
coude pour la création de cent cinquante
cent mille la première année 150 mise
cette année sur les emplois d'avenir
pour les jeunes si aujourd'hui on a une
maîtrise une diminution depuis neuf mois
du chômage des jeunes c'est parce que ce
gouvernement a mené une politique
volontariste largement d'ailleurs
critiqué par la droite mais c'est 150
mille jeunes 110000 aujourd'hui 150
mille demain vous parliez tout à l'heure
et avec juste raison de ces nouveaux
chômeurs qui sait de 30000 qui sont dans
la difficulté mais c'est 150 mille là on
peut aussi dire en face que ils ont
peut-être retrouver je dirais un peu
d'espoir dans la vie grâce au sco
damiano folle après second tour donc
françois hollande devrait s'exprimer
d'une façon ou d'une autre
est-ce que plus largement il doit ou est
ce qu'il peut et ce qu'il en a les
moyens vu les contraintes budgétaires
bruxelles changer quelque chose sur le
pack de responsabilité sur le cap qu'il
s'est fixé le 14 janvier je prends
beaucoup de socialistes le presse de le
faire lui dise
il y aura un avant et un après municipal
il faut changer quelque chose on a le
syndicaliste edouard martin qui le dit
aussi
qu'est ce qu'il peut faire je pense que
le problème qui existait avant les
élections municipales il existe toujours
après donc ce problème c'est que
aujourd'hui la france un problème de
compétitivité et que la france a un
problème de déficit du commerce
extérieur
il faut bien que comprendre une chose
c'est que on a une sorte de double peine
qui s'applique à nous pourquoi parce que
nos principaux partenaires notamment
l'allemagne et l'ensemble de la zone
euro est positif sur le plan du commerce
extérieur et c'est parce que il c'est
positif que laure haut et fort nous on a
à la fois une déficit important et on
supporte coûte 2 euros
et personne ne peut s'exonérer de cette
difficulté c'est pour ça que je parlais
tout à l'heure de la question du coût du
travail
il faut absolument dans ce pays que l'on
retrouve des éléments de compétitivité
et ceux qui oppose ceux que posent
chantant ses discours
ce qui oppose la politique de l'offre
avec la question de la une politique de
la demande c'est-à-dire la relance par
la consommation peut y avoir un
arbitrage intermédiaires et la question
peut se poser
mais c'est pas une autre politique ou
une politique alternative parce que
personne ne peut s'exonérer de la
question sur la compétitivité et ensuite
ça va être quand on est arrivé on a
trouvé un pays qui avait sur les dix
dernières années perdu 700 mille emplois
industriels
chacun comprend aujourd'hui si vous
remettez si vous relancez le savez donc
le statu quo sur ces questions là c'est
pas le seul
vous avez déjà aujourd'hui on l'a vu
j'ai parlé du coût du travail 20
milliards du ciel c'est eux qui vont
maintenant rentrer dans la compte dans
les comptes des entreprises pour
favoriser l'investissement les 10
milliards on discute avec les
entreprises vous avez vu au départ il y
avait l'idée est ce qu'il faut d'abord
baissé tout la cotisation des
allocations familiales ou est-ce qu'on
garde le cic e + 10 milliards est ce que
on voit d'abord sur les bas salaires ou
est ce qu'on voit sur la compétitivité
il ya un vrai débat parce que si on va
sur les bas salaires c'est plus une
mesure emploi ça c'était aujourd'hui en
train d'être débattue y compris avec le
chef d'entreprise à gauche vous a
reproché une partie de la gauche de
faire des cadeaux au patronat on a même
entendu le patron de la cgt
le vrai premier ministre c'est monsieur
gattaz et là est ce que vous allez
corrigé donc le pack est ce que vous
allez réorienter ajouté je ne sais pas
un volet social ou environnemental
opaque grille lorenzo les cadeaux au
patronat
ça serait sur le plan fiscal
quand on donne aux entreprises la
possibilité d'investir quand il ya des
investissements ça veut dire qu'il ya
des salariés derrière c'est en fait bon
fait en aide l'entreprise c'est une
entreprise c'est pas que les patrons
c'est aussi c'est aussi les salariés et
donc je pense que c'est une une vision
qui n'est pas qui n'est pas acceptable
nous sommes obligés d'avoir une
politique d'investissement le volet
contrepartie à ce tag de responsabilité
ce qui sera plus important sur le plan
social sur le plan écologistes comme le
réclament les écologistes qui sont qui
sont sur la france et sur la transition
sur la transition écologique tous avec
7,1 c'est un engagement pris par le
président de la république c'est une une
pomme texte de loi qui va venir devant
le parlement
je peux vous le dire à l'automne et
j'ajoute il ya une donnée particulière
est nouvelle sur la question de la
transition écologique c'est ce qui se
passe dans la sphère de l'ukraine parce
qu'en réalité l'une des décisions qu'on
va être obligé de prendre c'est de
réduire notre dépendance à la russie
donc notre dépendance au gaz et que à
cette question
la transition énergétique et écologique
devient aussi une questions
géostratégiques
au vu des résultats des municipales
quels sont pour vous les vos pronostics
pour les élections européennes
est ce que le ps risque d'être relégué
au plan de 2e 3e 4e parce qu'il ne veut
pas faire de pronostics je comprends que
il ya une inquiétude pour le ps dans
votre interrogation elle est bien elle
est bien logique et en même temps saf
c'est un lien avec notre débat et c'est
venu naturellement vous remercie de
l'avoir posée à ce moment-là profond
c'est là qu'est la vraie question sur
l'est sur les choix d'orientation soit
ces élections européennes vont se
transformer dans des élections pour ou
contre l'europe
et là c'est le front national qui va
gagner jusqu au fond je voulais dire ça
c'est un parti dans l'idéologie repose
de quoi sur la peur des gens on a peur
de tout la peur de l'europe la peur de
l'autre on va se refermer
autant de choses qui comptent très bien
tu as ton sur les liens d'amitié bien
sûr mais le bien partis pour arriver
premier être on n'a perdu que des
batailles qu'on m'aime pas je sais les
élections c'est le 25 mai il faudra
parler d'europe
beaucoup parlé d'europe et expliqué
qu'il n'y a pas qu'une seule
il ya aujourd'hui des difficultés à doha
il a des difficultés de croissance en
europe mais parce que il ya une
commission qui km2 droite parce qu'il ya
une majorité de droite au parlement
européen et que la question de ce que la
france puisse trouver dans une autre
majorité
en europe la possibilité d'accompagner
la reprise et donc d'accompagner le
choix de la croissance que l'on fait
aujourd'hui c'est un enjeu fondamental
c'est notre jeu ouais c'est pas la même
chose d'avoir monsieur barroso qui
dirige l'europe ou d'avoir martin schulz
est ce que c'est ça qu'il va falloir
faire comprendre aux gens il ya un vrai
choix politique tout aussi important que
le choix qu'ils forment pour les
élections municipales parce que ça
concerne leur vie quotidienne pour les
élections françaises
parce que la question européenne s'est
pas renvoyer à 17 ans ne vont pas
vouloir à nouveau sanctionné le
gouvernement au mois de mai pourquoi
vous savez je veux pas interpréter leur
vote l'électeur a toujours raison c'est
de notre responsabilité c'est de la
pédagogie c'est de la politique et ceux
que je viens d'expliquer bien je pense
qu'il faudra aller l'expliqué par tous
parce que vraiment si gens se mettent à
voter pour ou contre l'europe
alors effectivement imaginer ce qui va
se passer si on a un parlement européen
qui est constituée de gens
majoritairement hostile à l'europe parce
que ce dont on parle ici on parle du
front national
enfin tout le monde sait qu'il se passe
à peu près la même chose dans l'épée
d'un décès dans les autres pays
européens
la montée des nationalismes ne leur en
vendent email l'histoire se répète pas
moi je préfère être prudent dans ces cas
là on a un grand projet européen qui
pourrait être ce projet remis en cause
par des gens qui ont une vision qui est
uniquement de faire de l'europe un grand
marché c'est ça le fond d'affaires et
les gens ne veulent les gens ils veulent
l'europe parce que c'est un choix
politique mais ils veulent pas que
l'europe ce soit uniquement grands
marchés nous non plus mais c'est ce
choix qu'ils feront le 25 mai en votant
vous aimeriez par exemple que la
commission européenne desserrent l'étau
budgétaire pour ne pas favoriser c'est
votre populisme partout en europe par
exemple ne serait-ce que de modifier les
normes comptables par exemple si on
sortait des déficits des investissements
qui sont des investissements d'avenir
chacun le comprend et il aurait il y
aurait aucun risque voilà des mesures
mais ça fait la différence entre la
vision étroite comptable que nous impose
aujourd'hui cette commission est ce que
nous demandons avec tous les socialistes
européens
chez les socialistes français ont
l'impression que le feu couve
certains soutiennent mais la marmite est
prête à exploser après dimanche est ce
que vous craignez un grand d un grand
déballage la curée vous devez être peu
plus renseigné comme moi beaucoup
s'exprimant quelques personnalités qui
quand même entre nous sont quand même
coutumier du fait donc mais aussi des
élus qui fait un petit calcul qui vont
voir qu'ils seront plus réélu dans trois
ans qui n'est pas d'inquiétude pour
notre monde mais pas d'inquiétude pour
l'adoption le vote aura lieu sur le
pacte responsabilité mais pas
d'inquiétude je suis ministre des
relations avec le parlement je suis pour
le respect des parlementaires le
gouvernement s'y est le premier ministre
est très attaché aussi un travail de
conviction de discussion il aura lieu ce
gouvernement n'est pas fermé à entendre
sa majorité est ce que ce que tu devras
être libre c'est sera pas une marmite
qui va exploser ça sera une discussion
sur qu'est ce qui s'est passé comment
vous avez ressenti des choses mais le
gouvernement parlera aussi pour dire
qu'on n'entend pas que l'ale deux du
parti dire il faut un peu revoir la
ligne tracée par le président de la
république
amar qui vont de plus en plus nous
aurons probablement a probablement ce
débat en même temps tout ça va tanguer -
tout ce que j'ai dit moi je suis
confiant ça va ça va pas tomber ça va
débattre c'est une bonne chose
parti socialiste est un parti est un
parti de débat télé car il rappelé il ya
un instant que les écologistes
finalement ce sont la seule force
politique sortir gagnant 1 des
municipales dans l'attelage
gouvernemental est ce que ça va leur
donner les droits supplémentaires au
sein du gouvernement le mois tu là j'ai
quand même un peu varié dans l'alliance
gouvernementale la majorité
présidentielle qu'est-ce qu'ils auront
un troisième ministère est ce qu ils
peuvent prétendre au ministère de
l'environnement traiter les problèmes
dont on vient de parler ce que vous
pensez que la solution à tout ça c'est
de savoir s'il faut une troisième
ministère n'a pas pour eux j'ai
l'impression que ça compte
franchement j'avais plus de respect pour
que vous attend mais c'est légitime en
même temps la zone si ça se présente pas
comme ça c'est le contenu c'est le fond
il va y avoir des débats que y compris
dans le débat avancent leurs arguments
oui c'est pas dire c'est pas c'est pas
une discussions d'épiciers franchement
si c'est vous aviez raison vous vous
iriez dans le sens de ceux qui se sont
abstenus je pense qu'yves il faut
affirmer une autre idée de la politique
assure bien sûr mais en tous les cas la
composition du gouvernement du futur
gouvernement
cl et dans tous les pays bas et c'est
bien de passer devant les journalistes
une un gouvernement avec une
architecture complètement différente des
pôles des grands pôles de responsabilité
des ministres et des secrétaires d'état
se donne débat qui est posée
pense qu'il est entre les mains du
président jeu juste levet d'une phrase
un faux débat je lis souvent tel au
grand pays à côté de chênois 18
ministres et condamne à prendre cette
tout ça il faut il en 18 min sme il ya
25 secrétaire d'état donc c'est un
gouvernement resserré n'existe pas
vraiment nancy le président peut choisir
notre périmètre dire effectivement une
expérience de ces deux années qui peut
conduire ce genre de réponse merci
karine ali avant d'accueillir perrine
tarneaud je vous propose maintenant
monsieur mise à les voir les efforts que
mène un des vôtres un candidat ps pour
tenter de mobiliser pour le second tour
on est à rosny-sous-bois en
seine-saint-denis la face au maire
sortant ump claude capillon qui est
arrivé largement en tête le candidat ps
donc arpente les quartiers populaires où
l'abstention dépasse allègrement les 50%
julien cholin ce soir les troupes
socialistes se lance à la reconquête des
quartiers populaires ici auprès gentil
l'abstention a atteint 55 % en moyenne
pour mobiliser la ligne de l'opposant
numéro un au maire claude capillon est
clair et net
on rentre pas dans l'animation la
politique nationale et cetera on dit aux
gens que le message est bien passé au
niveau du gouvernement
le message est bien passé il va et il y
aura les choses mais on est sur le local
1 le message est passé le vote sanction
a bien été entendu
alors une fois la porte ouverte place
aux enjeux locaux
les trottoirs les sens interdits les bus
municipaux
tout y passe autant parfois parler du
quartier peut convaincre ça soit la
droite à gauche
pourvu qu'on a quelque chose le temps
pour d'autres la pilule ne passe pas
foncier aller voter non non non pas du
tout je me suis dit cela
pense que françois hollande a quand même
compris le message et que dans les
semaines à venir il va y avoir
vraisemblablement des choses qui vont
changer
mais maintenant il s'agit de changer la
vie dans la ville faire campagne en
parlant remaniement décidément
l'impopularité du président pèse lourd
ce qui a été catastrophique et je le dis
sans retenue c'est la communication
faite par par le gouvernement que la
gauche fasse entrer des gens modestes
dans l'impôt qu'ils n'y étaient pas
avant c'est très très difficile de la
faire comprendre que ça c'est cesser
c'est la gauche qui doit le faire au
pied des immeubles une quinzaine de
jeunes interpelle le candidat aucun
accepte d'être filmé ici c'est la
rancoeur qui domine aussi ont voté
françois hollande en 2012 depuis rien
n'a changé alors cette fois ils n'iront
pas voter
pourtant dans le local du quartier
peut-être le signe qu'ils attendent
encore quelque chose de la politique
cette petite photo du maire claude
capillon scotché au drapeau du psg voilà
il y aura une quadrangulaire à
rosny-sous-bois dimanche tant qu avec
les listes de l'ump le maire sortant
claude capillon du ps qu'on a vu
philippe vacquier riz du modem pierre
olivier carell et du front national
daniel boost l'air un perrine tarneaud
et donc être avec nos bons soient
repérés aux questions à la vie mais je
les trouvais assez optimiste tout à
l'heure vous n'avez pas peur du grand
défouloir lors de la rentrée
parlementaire et lors des réunions de
groupe des groupes socialistes ici au
sénat et puis évidemment aussi à
l'assemblée nationale quand même vous
sentez pas cette amertume même cette
peine mis qu'un cherche certains élus
locaux qui ont peur de perdre leurs
sièges parce que là c'était des
élections municipales mais derrière il
ya les régionales il ya d'autres
méthodes qui vont être importantes sans
parler des sénatoriales en scène le
combat politique
il s'arrête pas même après une défaite
on parlait tout à l'heure de 2008 la
droite avec ou d'une défaite
considérable nous mêmes en 93 c'est la
pire défaite clown est connu on a
regagné en 97 les élections moi je pense
qu'il va y avoir un débat et c'est bien
normal et en plus on en a besoin puisque
les parlementaires notamment sont ceux
qui sont sur le terrain et donc sont des
interlocuteurs privilégiés pour le
gouvernement sur le résultat des
élections municipales il a aussi sur le
cap fixé par ce gouvernement où le
prochain gouvernement
oui mais on y brasse public oui oui qui
a été élu sur cette ligne là oui mais il
ya des explications à donner
j'entendais votre rêve reportage notre
candidat dit on ne comprend pas pourquoi
des personnes ayant un faible revenu
sont rentrés dans l'impôt pourquoi en
assumant sa question qui quand on écoute
les résultats prévient tout oui et alors
c'est quand même assez simple de
répondre qu'il ya deux mesures qui sont
à l'origine de ça qu'on n'a pas pu
remettre en cause qu'ils sont sains
le gel du barème de l'impôt pour deux
ans quand on est arrivé au pouvoir alors
que les caisses étaient vides et la
suppression de la demi part pour les
veuves qui a été prise avant et donc
quand on est arrivés du gouvernement
précédent mais quand vous arrivez que
c'est entre assumer ce qu'on a décidé
nous et assumer les conséquences de ce
qu'ont fait les autres et quand même une
marge
donc on peut répondre ça aux gens
d'autant plus qu'ils peuvent nous dire à
ce moment là oui mais vous aviez call
remettre en cause sauf que non seulement
il l'avait fait mais qu'en plus les
caisses étaient vides
voilà donc ça c'est toute la difficulté
de ce à quoi on a été confronté mais je
vais te peut l'expliquer assez
simplement engeance est-ce que vous même
vous avez pris un coup sur la tête dans
votre département des landes
moitié-moitié janvier il y en avait un
espoir de reconquête sur la ville
chef-lieu ça s'est pas bien passé mais
en même temps il a été élu dès le
premier tour
tu t'étais sortante il y avait une seule
liste de droite a été élu au premier
tour
en même temps la ville de dax qu'on a
appris que le deuxième but qu'on a pris
en 2008 et donc on pouvait normalement
apparaître comme étant en danger notre
candidat a fait un excellent score je
pense qu'il sera efficace que vous avez
été vous même surpris par l'ampleur de
ce vote sanction dimanche soir que
personne n'avait vraiment venir pas des
sondés en tous les cas ni vous le
responsable vous avez c'est l'ampleur de
l'abstention
l'abstention c'est l'ampleur de
l'abstention qui c'est à dire ce qu'on
appelle le différentiel d'abstention
c'est à dire l'électorat de droite est
forcément mobilisés depuis 2012 il
attend que ça va venir voter contre tout
ce qui ressemble de près ou de loin à la
gauche donc il l'a fait il ya rien à
dire et l'électorat de gauche mais comme
cela s'était passé dans toutes les
élections intermédiaires sauf que ça a
été probablement un peu plus un peu plus
un peu plus marqué voilà c'est tout mais
c'est pas non plus une surprise totale
l'ampleur oui aucune surprise quand on a
parlé tout à l'heure les élections
sénatoriales
ici on a vu au sénat tout le monde
sortira mouvaux sa calculette et
beaucoup d'où jean pierre raffarin
ancien premier ministre était hier sur
notre plateau le dise maintenant à
droite et une possibilité d'alternance
en septembre 2014 au sénat vous y croyez
faut partout où il ya des élections il
ya toujours une possibilité d'alternance
je ne vais pas faire des pronostics
d'abord moi je vis tout le monde
peut-être attendre le deuxième tour il
me surprend beaucoup c'est que la droite
triomphe comme si on distribuait les
prix non
il tire pour les élections sénatoriales
des conséquences à partir du premier
tour des élections municipales suffisant
probablement quand même aux jeux
olympiques on donne pas les médaillés à
la mi temps
jean pierre raffarin on va l'écouter
aussi il ait eu des mots assez durs
concernant le gouvernement sur
l'attitude du gouvernement vis-à-vis du
sénat écouter l'ancien premier ministre
ce qu'il faudra le moment venu c'est
qu'on ait une stratégie au fonds pour
sauver le sénat pour rénover le sénat
pour changer le sénat sont les lyonnais
et mais bien sûr on voit bien que le
sénat est en cause aujourd'hui le
gouvernement le marginalise on à l'aps
cependant le sentiment qui est une forme
d'indécence et surtout il y en a mais
oui mais ça c'est pas de notre fait
c'est parce qu'il ya eu un partage des
pouvoirs qui n'a pas correspondu à un
partage du projet alors quelle est votre
réaction est en campagne électorale pour
la présidence du sénat avant de
s'occuper de la gauche je pense qu'il
faudra d'abord qui s'occupe de ses
propres amis alors l'argument qui
consiste à dire ce gouvernement est
hostile au sénat non mais très
honnêtement moi je suis là toutes les
semaines il ya de bons débats au sénat
qu'il ya eu un partage du pouvoir ici au
sénat mais il n'y a pas de partages du
projet politique entre vous les
socialistes les verts ou encore les
communistes c'est surtout pas vous
n'allez pas découvrir ce qu'on a pas de
majorité ici au sénat donc c'est une
réalité qui explique que certain nombre
de textes ont été refusées mais il ya
procès à faire à personne par la droite
fait son travail pas au groupe
communiste qui est fidèle à ses
convictions
donc ensuite la procédure se déroule
mais vous savez des lois très
importantes sont passés en premier au
sénat c'est pas toujours été facile à
l'assemblée quand j'ai annoncé que la
loi de programmation militaire qui est
important pour des parlementaires elle
serait d'abord examiné au sénat à
l'assemblée on manie pas l'inversé si on
m'a dit quand même c'est donner au sénat
un rôle important non nous sommes pour
le bicamérisme très clairement nous ne
sommes pas favorables à la
spécialisation du sénat comme étant la
chambre
des collectivités locales pour être très
clair et nous reconnaissons sa
spécificité
donc ça c'est pas la réponse à jean
pierre raffarin sur le calendrier des
semaines à venir le calendrier
parlementaire est ce que dans ce
calendrier bien on va voir l'urgence
économique sociale marquée dans l'est
dans les semaines à venir
par exemple sur le pacte de
responsabilité est ce que ça va venir à
l'assemblée nationale vers le 15 16
avril vote de confiance comme celle
n'est plus comme c'est annoncé
non merci de pas avoir précisé l'heure
en plus ce sera pas dans le courant du
mois d'avril je ne sais pas exactement à
quelle date le président vous avez vous
avez vous avez la réponse je sais pas
nickel journée mais ce sera là donc ça
n'a pas de bon sens donc y aura une
déclaration à l'assemblée avec
l'engagement de responsabilité sur fond
de ma marque et 49 1 de la constitution
est-ce qu'il faut mettre au rancart
toutes les réformes sociétales et sans
contact dans l'économique et bien sûr
j'ai mal on pose la question sur que non
c'est pas là aussi sont des faux débat
pourquoi faudrait-il faire des choix
entre le social et le sociétal dans une
politique une politique c'est un tout il
ya des textes qui les résultats du
premier tour des municipales et bien
peut-être que le maillage pour tous a
finalement laissé des traces dans
l'opinion
c'est un move il disait l'électorat de
droite c'est clair enfin le lectorat de
droite
je ne veux pas être réceptif l'électorat
de droite hostiles à à ceux à ce texte
mais peut-être fallait-il que
l'électorat de gauche qui est favorable
justement considéré qu'il fallait clis
mobilise aussi pour soutenir ces
réformes importe donc au parlement d'ici
cet été il y aura des débats sur la
prostitution sur la fin de vie sur la
prostitution c'est prévu sur la fin de
vie c'est pas prévu avant la fin de
l'été pour répondre avant la des
vacances pour répondre très précisément
président vidic pour le monde déposera
un texte lu ce qu'on attend un certain
nombre d'avis avant la fin de l'année
de 2014 d'accord une un mot peut-être
sur la visite en france du président
chinois
est ce qu'au nom des intérêts
économiques il faut mettre de côté
toutes les questions sur les droits de
l'homme
c'est pas les mettre de côté je pense
que quand le président de la république
est allé l apprendre la visite
écoutez vous savez très bien comment ça
se passe c'est sont forcément abordé
dans des discussions qui sont des
discussions de chefs d'état chefs d'état
mais elles n'ont pas la france n'a pas
décidé de ne pas reconnaître ce qu'est
l'importance de ses relations
économiques avec la chine voilà c'est
l'hiver et la compression
ils ont écrit à françois hollande
nivelles que l'ambassadrice de france en
chine se rendre au tibet oui mais sait
on qu'on connaît leur position là-dessus
mais je veux dire l'espèce de monde
idéal dans lequel on aurait des rapports
économiques et diplomatiques qu'avec des
gens parfaits je respire je le souhaite
ça veut pas dire ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut renoncer au débat non on sait très
bien que c'est la realpolitik en même
temps la france est porteur et on le
sait très bien et ce ceux qui se battent
dans ces pays pour conquérir des droits
ils veulent qu'on continue à avoir des
relations avec leur pays parce que c'est
là qu'on est le plus efficace et que
ceux qui s'ils ont une position radicale
se trouve justement parce que si on n'a
plus de rapport
alors la place et est nette et ils ont
besoin effectivement que l'on soit n'est
reconnue des interlocuteurs par leur
pays ne serait ce que pour faire
améliorer des sharks en tous les cas ce
qui prime aujourd'hui ce sont les
accords commerciaux il y en a une
cinquantaine quoi était signé à l'elysée
pour un total de 18 milliards d'euros on
parlera du tibet après c'est pas l'un ou
l'autre des droits de l'homme c'est pas
l'un ou l'autre j'ai cru part je trouve
que votre observation des périodes alors
c'est pas l'un ou l'autre il peut être
question des deux choses il ya eu des
positions qui ont été données par la
france en matière de politique étrangère
franchement franchement si un pays qui
est au rendez vous aujourd'hui pour
défendre la démocratie y compris quand
tous les autres s'échappe parfois c'est
la france on est allé au mali il y avait
un massacre en centrafrique au nlhe et a
laissé des soldats français je le rends
hommage et c'est la décision du
président de la république alors il
paraît qu'on peut parler effectivement
théo président enchaînements mais il est
bon de le prévenir par avance donc c'est
ce qui a dû être préparé en coulisses on
verra ce soir tous les cas merci ça
s'appelle de la diplômée ça s'appelle de
la diplomatie merci c'est parfois
efficace et pérenne toi merci beaucoup à
la vie d'alice d'avoir été avec nos
bancs sera tout ça très vite